thank you for joining us here at noon
i'm christian casadis we're continuing
to follow the condition of
nhp trooper micah may this afternoon
after
he was hit on i-15 during a wild chase
on tuesday
eight news now reporter joe muller joins
us live from the university medical
center with an update joe
christian trooper may remains in
critical condition here at umc the
public information officer from nhp came
up to us about 30 minutes ago and says
we should be getting another update
later on today here's a live look at the
hospital
at this hour there are a number of
troopers still outside the front door
as they have been for the past two days
about an hour ago we watched as more
family members were escorted to the
hospital
trooper travis smacka says there is
family from all over the country here
now two days after the incident smacka
says we should learn more about may's
condition and today will be
very telling he says the support from
law enforcement and the community
has been overwhelming it goes back to
the horrible 901 october
where this is a city where we all come
together and
we work well together and we're all
brothers and sisters even though we work
for different agencies
smacka says trooper may is in critical
condition but is breathing right now
because of the quick decision of the
metro helicopter pilot landing on the
freeway to
take him to the hospital now back out
here live and i'm talking about the
outpouring of support uh smeka also told
us a short time ago the father of
metro officer shea mccollonas who was
shot in a protest
last summer actually came here and
delivered items and even water to people
waiting outside
he says the best way if you wanted to
help is the injured police officers fund
we do have a link for that
up on our website that is
eightnewsnow.com reporting live outside
of umc
john muller 8 news now